[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag à spécial
élections municipales les français ont
la parole pendant toute cette campagne
on va tenter de comprendre quelles sont
vos préoccupations au quotidien avec nos
reportages sur le terrain vos remarques
et notre sondage sur nos réseaux sociaux
et puis bien sûr notre débat aujourd'hui
on va parler pouvoir d'achat avec nos
invités sur ce plateau
benoît ourliac administrateurs à l'insee
face avoue philippe herlin économiste et
auteur de pouvoir d'achat
le grand mensonge aux éditions eyrolles
et puis nicolas vidal directeur de
publication de putsch médias merci à
tous d'avoir accepté notre invitation et
sur rt france alors que le gouvernement
a mis la main à la poche 17 milliards
d'euros depuis le début de la crise et
gilet jaune un près d'un français sur
deux a l'impression d'en avoir toujours
moins dans son porte monnaie
pourtant le pouvoir d'achat a bien
augmenté selon diverses statistiques
illustration dans le grand est où la
moitié de la population à boire affirme
avoir toujours des fins de mois est
difficile et vous allez voir à
strasbourg
les restos du coeur ne connaissent pas
la crise un reportage signé nadège
abderrazak et jordi demory un pouvoir
d'achat en déclin un sentiment qui
prédomine dans cette ville de strasbourg
et il est exacerbé dans les locaux des
restos du coeur association qui vient en
aide à près de 13000 personnes dans le
bas rhin
parmi elles l'yonne qui témoignent à
visage couvert
à 42 ans son seul objectif est de
nourrir ses deux enfants ses loisirs
personnels
elle a mis une croix dessus je m'appelle
sur les priorités
le reste je me dis que ce n'est
qu'accessoire quoi qu'est ce que par
exemple vous pouvez pas vous achetez de
par exemple mes propres dans mes propres
besoins se faire plaisir comme toutes
les dames je peux pas le faire
je suis allée chez le coiffeur je peux
pas aller chez le coiffeur comme je peux
le haut comme je le faisais avant
et le cinéma c'est lyon pas du tout non
jamais non je suis jamais allé depuis
que je suis en forme et offrir pour moi
c'est un luxe quoi beaucoup je le mets
de côté puis je me sens le nécessaire
vivre au jour le jour
l'histoire de l'yonne est loin d'être un
cas isolé et bénévole depuis près de 23
ans et léa on a vu bien d'autres
il ya 23 ans on avait moins de personnes
donc vous donner plus
chaque semaine il y avait à nouveau des
nouveaux des nouvelles personnes qui
sont là qui ont besoin et tout ça ça
augmente voiliers et puis bon bain
malheureusement
ça s'arrange pas quand vous voyez que
vous avez eu des parents qui faisaient
ils avaient des enfants de 10 12 ans 14
ans 15 ans et maintenant celui des
enfants qui viennent chercher des aux
restos du coeur
mais moi ça me fait ça me touche quand
même parce que je me dis ça ne va plus
exister ce genre de show une détresse
financière qui se propage au plus grand
nombre
un français sur deux affirme recourir
aux découverts bancaires pour boucler
ses fins de mois
je trouve que c'est très dur la vie en
ce moment c'était mieux avant pourquoi
c'est dur aujourd'hui parce tout est
beaucoup plus cher et puis la retraite
ça n'augmente pas dans une petite
retraite j'ai pioche des fois dans le
petit capital que j'ai un petit peu de
côté pour pour finir des fois les mois
sinon je n'arrive pas disons que l'avion
monte on se rend compte le pain le
courant au marché on voit que les prix
d'une année sur l'autre augmente
un petit peu les timbres l'électricité
enfin bon le tout ce qu'on dont on a
besoin
actuellement on arrive quand même donc
avoir quelques difficultés fin du mois
et du coup on fait attention quand même
par rapport aux prix et
voilà tout le monte en termes de
factures de gaz électricité
quand on regarde tous les prélèvements
en ce moment a pas vraiment l'impression
d'être plus riche qu'avant j'ai jamais
vérifier les prix de ma vie mais depuis
je suis retraité oui je vérifie
absolument tout et je vais toujours au
moins cher voilà cette perspective
négative sur le pouvoir d'achat est une
spécificité française philippe herlin
alors que dans l'europe
en tout cas ce sentiment de baisse du
pouvoir d'achat est beaucoup plus faible
il était à 32 %
il existe quand même mais en france il
réel votre porte là je vais montrer mais
il ya régulièrement des sondages qui
sont faits qui montrent qu'en grosso
modo les trois quarts des français
considèrent que leur pouvoir d'achat
diminue donc là je crois qu'il ya une
prise de conscience donc il faut avoir
aussi bien à l'insee que les autorités
politiques et c'est moi je rapprocherais
ça démoule phénomène de l'insécurité il
ya une dizaine d'années en parler de
sentiment d'insécurité quand les
françaises plaignants leur zone mais
c'est un sentiment d'insécurité
et puis on trafique a les statistiques
pour avoir une stabilité aujourd'hui les
statistiques pourquoi pour le porno
sécurité pour faire croire que c'est est
stable aujourd'hui maintenant là pour le
coup voilà par le ministère l'intérieur
à l'époque voilà bon aujourd'hui plus
personne aussi bien à droite qu'à gauche
plus personne ne conteste que
l'insécurité augmente et est un problème
là on a le même problème pour pouvoir
d'achat les trois quarts des français
pensent qu'ils baissent et l'insee nous
affirme qu'il augmente donc il ya un
moment il faut il faut mettre les choses
au clair sur la façon de calculer le
pouvoir d'achat il pouvoir d'achat c'est
très simple c'est l'augmentation des
salaires mois l'augmentation des prix
mais on comprend dans cette équation que
si les primes aussi l'augmentation des
prix est sous-estimé ça va permettre de
dégager un pouvoir d'achat mais qui sera
plus factice qui utilisera par ariel
gouvernementale qui s'ajoute à ça nous
met évidemment on va en parler justement
de ce décalage puisque nous avons un
benoît ourliac inde de l'insee comment
comment est ce que l'insee calcule ce
fameux pouvoir d'achat qui fait débat en
tout cas alors d'abord peut-être jeu
j'ai envie de revenir sur ce sentiment
de décalage que l'on qui a été exprimée
ici encore sur ce plateau entre le
ressenti des français et puis les
statistiques de l'insee publie sur le
pouvoir d'achat
ce que j'aimerais vraiment dire c'est
expliqué c'est que que raconte
exactement ces statistiques ce qu'elles
décrivent c'est quand même une situation
qui est inédite aujourd'hui en france
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale
ce qu'il faut bien avoir en tête c'est
que le pouvoir d'achat des ménages dans
les statistiques de l'insee a stagné
depuis pendant près de dix ans c'est à
dire sur la période allant de 2007 à
2018 il a il a stagné
si on regarde plus dans le détail on
peut décomposer en deux phases on a eu
une première phase après la crise
financière ou le pouvoir d'achat a
diminué
ça aussi c'est dans notre satistiques
n'importe qui peut aller constater c'est
ce que l'on raconte
il a reculé de 2007 à 2013 grosso modo
enfin exactement et ensuite il s'est
redressé depuis 2013 il a commencé à
réaugmenter très timidement où on est
sur des progressions comprises entre 0 %
et 1 % par an donc on est quand même sur
des choses qui sont aussi très faible on
a on ne raconte pas que le pouvoir
d'achat est en train de s est en train
d'exploser et de fait de ce rythme
modéré ce n'est que en 2018 qu'il a
retrouvé son niveau de 2007 donc son
niveau de onze ans auparavant donc on a
vraiment une période de stagnation
pendant pendant 11 ans et ce qu'il faut
rappeler aussi c'est que cette
statistique dont tout le monde parle
c'est une moyenne
c'est une moyenne dans la tranche par
tranche évidemment quand on regarde par
ma chance est différent et quand on a un
pouvoir d'achat qui fait du surplace en
moyenne pour l'ensemble de la population
comme toute moyenne il ya des gens qui
sont au dessus il ya des gens qui sont
au dessous donc un pouvoir d'achat qui a
stagné pendant plus de dix ans en
moyenne ça veut dire que pour une
fraction serait significative de la
population
ce pouvoir d'achat a baissé on y
reviendra dans les détails à savoir
comment et sur quoi vous basez un
évidemment qu est-ce qui rentrent en
ligne de compte dans la prise en compte
notamment de l'inflation etc
nicolas vidal vous vous êtes journaliste
français également vous avez suivi
beaucoup cette crise des gilet jaune on
le voit dans la rue encore tous les
samedis c'est le compte n'y est pas
effectivement il ya cette idée
aujourd'hui que moi je suis ce débat est
passionnant très sincèrement parce que
j'ai pris conscience entre en moyenne
l'émission qui avait un énorme décalage
de perception effectivement mais vous
avez par exemple la revue de presse vous
avez la presse on va dire un peu plus à
gauche qui dénonce la non augmentation
de pouvoir d'achat donc sa baisse et
puis la presse plus libérale qui dit que
tout va bien ou du moins qu'il ya une
augmentation il ça c'est extrêmement
intéressant pour nous analyste politique
du moins un observateur
parce qu'on se rend compte que
finalement la critique chez les jeunes
est passé par là et qu'aujourd'hui il ya
encore une norme compréhension et je
termine notamment même christine lagarde
président de la bce a dit
qu'effectivement il fallait commencer à
gommer la différence de perception
j'aime toujours moi l'envolée des mots
perception et mais on parle de
perception alors qu'on le voit les en
tout cas de ce qu'on l'envoie des
témoignages des français c'est du réel
finalement c'est pas forcément de la
perception
ils savent très bien faire le calcul
quand on a 1000 euros par mois on sait
ce qu'on dépense on sait ce qu'on gagne
et à la fin c'est moins on sait plus
philippe herlin qu'est ce qui pèse sur
le pouvoir d'achat réellement vous vous
avez écrit un livre justement sur le
grand mensonge à l'art en quoi
consistent les mois je parle père
stagnation je parle de baisse et des
2000 pour quelles raisons c'est à partir
de 2000 qu'on voit une forte
augmentation du logement des prix des
logements en france
et ça ça pèse quelque et ça ça fait
énormément sur le budget des ménages
parce que c'est un budget important pour
ceux qui achètent alors tout le monde
l'achète pas même le grès fort mais ça
pèse
et ça pèse aussi sur les loyers avec un
peu de retard parce que les loyers
s'adapte au prix du neuf avec quelques
années de retard
bon et ça ne s est pas perçue par
l'inflation parce que le calcul que fait
l'insee a paris il prend un panier moyen
d'un panier de la ménagère on va dire un
panier moyen dans lequel l'immobilier
pèsent représentent 6% seulement vous
n'y a pas beaucoup de monde en france
qui ne consacre que 6 % de ce budget au
loyer alors d'où ça vient c'est parce
que l'heure de vous dis tiens ça peut
même aller jusqu'à 30 ce peut être plus
voilà alors une c2 prend en compte que
les lots que les loyers et pas
l'acquisition parce que l'acquisition on
acquiert un bien donc c'est un
investissement ceci dit le logement
c'est ainsi et c'est un bien un
investissement mais que l'on consomme et
puis ça rapporte pas d'argent
bon si on achète à un studio et quand le
nom en location ça c'est un placement et
ça n'a rien à faire dans l' indice des
prix on est d'accord mais le logement
principal qu'on achète pour habiter le
fait qu'ils soient totalement exclue
de l' indice des prix c'est quand même
un peu spécieux maintenance une norme
européenne je ne discute pas mais en
tant qu'économiste magie 10 et je dis
que c'est une erreur et ce qui fait que
toute la hausse des prix à partir de
2004 touchez pas seulement paris et les
grandes villes mais toute la france est
bien l'école est passée à l'as et ce qui
fait que lindsay a pu continuer d'
annoncer des hausses de pouvoir d'achat
alors que les français dont beaucoup à
guéret et pierre-yves logement et
notamment et où se glissent et qui se
relaient sur le rond-point et gilet
jaune
ils ont dû se serrer la ceinture de plus
en plus et où il n'arrivait pas à
boucler leur budget et et c'est ça qui
permet en partie à nous très faible
effet qualité aussi mais c'est ça qui
permet en partie d'expliquer la
différence et la différence de
perception entre la perception il
annonce officielle voilà et je crois
qu'il faudrait qu'il ya un débat
là-dessus qu'on avance et et vous avez
parlé la bce tout à l'heure ça c'est
très intéressant parce que la banque
l'économiste en chef de la banque
centrale européenne a déclaré récemment
qu'il fallait plus prendre en compte
l'immobilier dans le calcul de
l'inflation donc lui aussi il est
conscient de ce problème là donc je ne
suis pas tout seul et voilà enfin moi je
m'appuie aussi sur deux rapports
2007-2008 qui sont cons dénoncer ça
aussi bon à l'époque personne n'a parlé
parce que personne et les rapports mais
cherche mappy soucis sur des éléments
jusqu'à le premier à l'avoir découvrir
évidemment mais là maintenant la bce en
parle et c'est intéressant alors
pourquoi la bce en parle c'est parce que
les prix de l'immobilier augmentent en
allemagne et en allemagne
ils ont une meilleure culture monétaire
40 parce qu'ils ont subi le libéra façon
223 ils comprennent que la planche à
billets le quantitative easing de la bce
la création d'euro va se traduire par
des bulles immobilières et là il ya une
bulle immobilière en allemagne les gens
qui commencent voila voila et il
commence à dire la bce il ya un problème
voilà la bce pour contenir un peu le
problème dit oui effectivement il
faudrait qu'on tienne plus compte de
l'immobilier dans l'inflation dont la le
débat progresse en tout cas au niveau de
la bce donc ça c'est intéressant jeu des
questions techniques et concrètes donc
vous parler du logement est ce que les
dépenses contraintes type santé sont
prises en compte est ce que les dépenses
pré engagées à ce qu'on avait les
abonnements internet télévision et c'est
ce que s'est pris en compte aussi ça
alors oui c'est pas encore l'insee face
aux critiques qui avaient sur le pouvoir
d'achat en zone et 2007 2008 à peu près
à ce moment là d'ailleurs où on a
commandé des deux rapports sur le sujet
l'insee a calculé les notions de
dépenses pré-engagées dépenses
contraintes
bon alors c'est vrai les abonnements
téléphone tout ça c'est pas des choses
qu'on peut couper le jour au lendemain
on peut pas se priver de téléphone ses
dépens voilà epb la plus grosse part de
ces dépenses pré engagées c'est
l'immobilier
qui a augmenté en poids voilà il ça
augmente emplois dans les dépenses pré
engagées mais ça se retrouve pas dans l'
indice des prix voilà ce qui permet
ensuite de dire vous de pouvoir d'achat
augmente banon est la réponse de loi
ourliac est ce que le logement est
sous-évalué dans vos statistiques
est-ce que qu'est-ce que ce famille au
fameux paniers sur lequel vous vous
basez pour alors effectivement on se
chie de 6% on l'entend et il peut
naturellement surprendre je suis tout à
fait conscient de ça mais je pense qu'il
faut quand même bien expliquer ce que
représente ce 6 % ceci pour cent c'est
la part moyenne des loyers dans les
dépenses de consommation des ménages
ça veut dire que il s'agit d'une moyenne
donc ça c'est comme l'a dit me faire là
il ya nécessairement des gens qui sont
au dessus des gens qui sont en dessous
et d'une moyenne qui concerne l'ensemble
des ménages
donc il ya des ménages qui sont
propriétaires qui par définition ne paye
pas de loyer des ménages qui sont
locataires qui eux payent un loyer les
charges
il ya des charges mais encore une fois
ce rsa concerne l'assurance vie pour
cent c'est que le dépenses de loyer de
locataires et de loyer donc déjà si on
regarde uniquement les locataires la
part moyenne des loyers dans leurs
dépenses de consommation elle est plutôt
autour de 20 % sachant qu encore une
fois que c'est une moyenne et qu'on sait
très bien qu'il ya des voies bien dans
nos enquêtes ya des gens pour qui cette
part des locataires pour qui cette peur
d'atteindre 40 % voire des pertes
dépassent 40 % pour un cinquième des
ménages locataires la part des loyers
c'est plus de 40 % de leur budget de
leur budget et ensuite comme vous l'avez
dit c'est uniquement le loyer il ya
aussi toutes les autres charges
associées au logement c'est à dire les
charges locatives les dépenses d'eau
d'électricité de gaz l'enlèvement des
ordures ménagères et déjà cinq si on
rajoute c'est la taxe d'habitation sa
part maintenant dans la taxe
d'habitation c'est pas de la
consommation c'est pour ça que
elle est pas intégrée dans la
statistique d'un indice des prix à la
consommation mais si on rajoute tout ça
déjà on atteint 14% pour la totalité des
dépenses liées au logement dans le
panier de l'indicé des prix à la
consommation et pour finir effectivement
c'est un indice des prix qui mesure les
dépenses de consommation et donc on
exclut de ça tout ce qui est lié à de
l'investissement parce que nous on
appelle de l'investissement c'est à dire
les achats les achats immobiliers dont
les pro b donc on peut a concerné tout à
fait d'accord mais on peut pas reprocher
à un indice de ne pas mesurer ce
pourquoi il n'est pas construit et quand
on parle du pouvoir d'achat c'est comme
quand aux journalistes alors qu'ils
prennent peut-être kg prennent en compte
en tout est dans le nom
tout est dans le nom s'appelle indice
des prix à la consommation et et le
gouvernement évidemment s'appuie sur ces
chiffres un nicolas vidal
il ya beaucoup de mesures depuis cette
crise et gilet jaune prises par le
gouvernement on va les voir à l'écran
je vous propose d'abord d'écouter
emmanuel macron et vous vous commenterez
après je considère pour ma part que j'ai
apporté les réponses aux françaises et
aux français sur ce qui avait conduit à
ce mouvement à la fois le 10 décembre et
dans la conférence de presse que j'ai de
demain je crois que celles et ceux qui
continuent aujourd'hui à faire cela il
n'y a plus de débouché politique n'est
plus de débouchés politiques
donc nous avons fait notre part du
travail je pense que maintenant chacun
doit aller voter aux élections quand il
porte des idées se présenter aux
élections et c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de proches de proposer un
projet pour que d'être contre contre
tout le reste donc vous et on n'avance
pas en étant contre donc là aujourd'hui
je vois beaucoup de gens qui sont contre
donc j'appelle moi tout le monde au
calme
je pense que notre il ya trop de
violence aujourd'hui dans notre société
je considère donc que j'ai fait ma mais
j'ai apporté des réponses aux français
j'ai fait ma part a dit emmanuel macron
vous êtes d'accord avec ça mais vous
connaissez ma réponse vous savez je vais
vous dire non je l'aï emmanuel bach rond
il s'adresse à qui s'adresse à la france
périphérique
il s'adresse au gilet jaune il s'adresse
à la france oubliée sur le logement par
exemple sur le prix du loyer
vous avez paris vous avez la
métropolisation des grandes villes où le
loyer augmente mais les territoires
oubliés ceux qui sont fans qui doivent
prendre leur voiture les gie des jeunes
avec la techno zèle c'est ça aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron si on revient de façon
pour être concret et et factuel on va
sur une baisse d apn la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
on va sur une émission
rien on va sur toute une série de
réformes qui à mon sens va faire encore
baisser
peut-être pouvoir d'achat mais du moins
très carisaie faibles les plus faibles
mais on en revient pour rendre avec avec
nos invités mais je pense qu'il ya aussi
le fait que ces gens sont extrêmement
précarisés et je crois que la classe
moyenne qui s'est fait après m'être
conclure gaz a peut-être été
complètement happé par une paupérisation
et à glisser petit à petit vers pas
durer car populaire ne soyons pas
extrémiste mais je crois que c'est que
classes moyennes inférieures qui a
énormément grossi qui a une
extrapolation incroyable et je crois qu
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui avec les
mesures qui sont entre deux prises je
suis pas persuadé qu'il va régler le
problème
concrètement voilà pour mon vision
politique homo ni démon des critères
politiques
philibert à vous êtes d'accord 17
milliards d'injecter le pouvoir d'achat
augmenter néanmoins oui elle a signé il
ya un traitement comptable il ya un
certain il ya des français qu'on doit
plus d'argent sur leur compte en banque
c'est incontestable le problème le
problème c'est que c'est pas viable à
long terme parce que c'est de l'argent
qui est financé par la dette quoi on
peut distribuer de l'argent comme ça
c'est pas ça qui marche qui permet
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat de façon
importante sur le long terme c'est des
gains de productivité c'est ce que
j'explique je me base sur ce genre
fourastié voilà c'est ça qui permet
lorsqu'il faut serrer industrialisés la
france s'est libéré le capital libéré
donc baisser les impôts baisser les
normes bureaucratique et puis c'est ce
cas là il ya déjà des choses qui ont été
faites avec un impact qui vont quand
même dans le bon sens la suppression de
l'sf ça va dans le bon sens le certain
nombre de choses qui ont été faites qui
apporte et on voit quelques résultats
sur la baisse du chômage bon voilà
maintenant c'est pas du tout au niveau
de ce qu'il faudrait être donc il faut
s'attaquer à il faut d'autres mieux
dynamiser des économies et puis il faut
aussi aussi 7 à commercy de logements
pourquoi le logement il cher en france
par rapport aux autres pays parce qu'on
est en droit de la construction qui est
extrêmement contraint c'est très
compliqué de construire
c'est très compliqué d'augmenter les
surfaces donc ça fait monter les prix
alors c'est avantageux qui possèdent ce
avantageux qui sont déjà dans la place
qu'ont déjà un capital qui voient la
valeur de ce capital augmenté mais ceux
qui veulent rentrer et bien c'est très
compliqué il reste locataire longtemps
et quand ils veulent acheter ils sont
obligés de se serrer la ceinture
on prendre des petites surfaces donc il
faut libéraliser le marché de logements
et ça ça va permettra ensuite de faire
baisser les prix en tout cas qu'ils ont
moins vite et à ce moment là on pourra
avoir une augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat basée sur des choses saines
plutôt que de distribuer de l'argent
avec capable il ya aussi la hausse des
salaires vous en avez parlé est ce que
ça c'est aussi une des clés
nicolas vidal et les salaires stagnent
ça aussi c'est un problème pour les
français
oui certes acte mais je voudrais revenir
sur l'idée de libéralisme effectivement
la mondialisation qu'elle nous a
beaucoup touché c'est à dire quand on a
ouvert d'europe on à la guerre de tous
contre tous au sein de même de l'union
européenne
regardez d'entreprises sont à les
délocaliser en pologne en roumanie dans
d'autres pays donc on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec une perte au bloc prv
massive et je lisais ce matin que ne
serait-ce que depuis je crois entre 2001
et 2010 il ya eu pratiquement 270 mille
suppressions d'emploi à cause de
l'importation chinoise
on imagine bien que dans ce grand marché
mondialisé les c'est la france
périphérique qui en souffre le plus
et c'est cette fracture est là et là ont
quand même c'est pour ça que le curseur
entre libéralisme non n'y a pas d'accord
parce que si la france a souffert la
bande et lisa sion ou c'est parce que
les entreprises françaises ont des
boulets aux pieds c'est parce que la
france est le pays qui a le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires quand on fait
la somme de tous les impôts cotisations
etc
on a le taux le plus élevé des pelles
ocde donc tu aux entreprises ont dont un
boulet au pied donc évidemment elles
sont elles perdent des parts de marché
sont des licences et parfois ils font
faillite moi je suis convaincu que la
france a suffisamment de génie propre et
de créateurs d'entreprise et en plus on
est assez bon dans des domaines très
différents que ce soit le l'art de vivre
où la haute technologie où le luxe on
est en dépôt est pompeux avoir déconné
de diversifier les longs relais et
dynamique et asseoir des français des
gens qui sont non qualifiés diplômes non
qualifiés c'est-à-dire que le tertiaire
par exemple va exclure de fait toute une
partie des français qui seront pas
qualifiés et la perte des musiques
séparatisme sur le carreau beaucoup
beaucoup de la corvée son élection on a
beaucoup de gens pas clarifié sa cause
de l'éducation nationale qui fait très
noir auliac on a dit que c'est
et cette hausse est en tout cas du
pouvoir d'achat bénéficié à 70% des
français
est-ce que vous pouvez nous décrire un
petit peu qu'ils aient plus avantagés
que d'autres sur cette hausse du pouvoir
d'achat selon l'insee alors là dessus
tout à l'heure je vous ai dressé un peu
le port le tableau de l'évolution du
pouvoir d'achat de 2010 2007 à 2018 la
sur l'année 2019 donc l'année qui a été
impactée par les mesures prises à la
suite vous mangez les jeunes on en est
encore qu à des estimations provisoires
qui table plutôt sur une augmentation de
1,6 pour cent du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages
vous étiez à 2,1 pour cent soit en 2019
en fait ça dépend comment on le mesure
le pouls et le pouvoir d'achat à 2,1
pour cent que vous citez celle
indicateurs macroéconomiques qui mesure
le pouvoir d'achat de l'ensemble des
ménages mais ça c'est un indicateur qui
est
et à juste raison qui est très éloigné
du ressenti des ménages parce qu'il ne
tient pas en compte de l'évolution de la
population le fait que la population
augmente tous les ans et puis le fait
aussi de la composition des ménages
évoluent on a un mouvement en france qui
est que les mène la taille des ménages
diminue et ça ça entraîne des surcoûts
parce qu'on ne bénéficient pas des
économies déjà les diverses et voilà
exactement
et si on tient compte de ça c'est ce que
nous on appelle dans le jargon désolé
pour le terme d unité de consommation si
on tient compte de l'augmentation des
unités de consommation le pouvoir
d'achat tel qu'on le prévoit pour
l'année 2019 saugues serait en
augmentation de 1,6 pour cent
donc on voit qu'on est déjà un peu mieux
que ce que l'on a fait depuis depuis
2013 avec où on avait plutôt des
évolutions qui était comprise entre 0 et
1%
c'est quand à savoir les aurois oui ces
quelques tous les ans et quant à savoir
pour qui va en bénéficier la très
honnêtement c'est encore trop tôt pour
le dire
dans les dernières baies pour l'année on
peut parler d'eux alors très là encore
on a un décalage de un an et demi entre
la fin d'une année et le moment où on
est capable de
produire des statistiques permettent de
jongler sur base et de telle ou telle
mesure donc pour l'instant c'est encore
trop tôt pour savoir en 2018 qui déjà
qui a qui a gagné qui a perdu et ses
orientations
on sait que les plus précaires ne sont
pas finalement les gagnants de cette
affaire c'était intéressant ce que vous
venez dire parce que en fait on se rend
compte qu'il ya deux chiffres du pouvoir
d'achat voilà celui donc celui par unité
de consommation vous en expliquer qui
stagnait pendant dix ans j'ai jamais
entendu un responsable politique
français reconnaître que le pouvoir
d'achat avec stagné pendant dix ans
parce que ils prennent le chiffres qui
les arrangent
ils prennent le chiffre du pouvoir
d'achat donc la sepa l'insee qui oppose
1 lille s'est produite de chemin et ils
font ils font leur travail les reçus
voilà et c'est transparent mais le
pouvoir politique prend le chiffre qui
la range de plus et il dit le pouvoir
d'achat augmente et il prend pour achat
global évidemment s'en prend parité de
consommation avec le taux de divorce et
familles monoparentales
ça fait baisser chiffres automatiquement
voilà donc il vaut mieux prendre le
chiffre global c'est ce que c'est pas
pour les politiques oui les politiques
qui prennent le chiffre global
il est un peu plus élevée voilà on va
écouter à présent le ce qui fait baisser
aussi ce pouvoir d'achat ce sont ce sont
les frais bancaires ufc que choisir a
analysé cette situation et elle demande
la suppression des fameuses agios
écouter concernant les les frais
bancaires on s'est rendu compte que les
banques continuent à prélever ce qu'on
appelle des commissions d'intervention
en cas d'opération à découvert et ses
commissions d'intervention elles sont
anciennes et avant elle le rémunérer des
démarches ont été faites à la main par
les banques aujourd'hui tout est
automatisé
elle continue à prélever 2 8 milliards
d'euros de commissions d'intervention
sur les personnes qui font des paiements
découvert principalement les plus
modestes et donc nous demandons la
suppression de ces de ces commissions
d'intervention pour rendre du pouvoir
d'achat aux consommateurs dans la mesure
où aujourd'hui ces frais ne sont pas
justifiées ce sont des frais sanction et
non plus des freins qui rémunère un
travail fait par les banques
des frais sanction nicolas vidal qui
touchent évidemment les plus précaires
se sont bien sûr parce que c'est des
gens qui sont précarité dans les banques
et qui ont besoin qui font appel à ce
genre ou qui sont passées par ce genre
de chasse et et j'écoutais les frais
bancaires c'est une chose
les contrôles techniques vous imaginez
qu'un article sortie il ya de moins en
moins de gens qui font nos contrôles
techniques n'ont qu'un de plus en plus
de voitures
effectivement qui roulent sans cantine
parce que les gens est
voilà ce que les nombres de points ont
augmenté de moins de contrôles pardon
parlant de points parce que là je verrai
de points de contrôles qui augmentent et
donc les gens ne veulent pas payer plus
donc ils roulent sans contrôle technique
est autre chose
les pv les comptes sur l'information
on l'appelle 2019 apparemment je leur
chiffre à préciser mais c'est plus de 2
milliards de gains double passage aux 80
km heure chers amis je pense que là il
ya eu quand même une volonté de faire
entrer un peu d'argent dans les caisses
parce que ça c'est un impôt direct tibet
quittant ce qui quittant ce qui la
france périphérique une nouvelle fois
les gens qui habitent dans la creuse
dans l'allier pas les parisiens parce
que par exemple 50% par exemple la
voiture mais il va effectivement de
taper immédiatement sur les gens qui
habitent loin des métropoles qui ont
besoin de prendre la voiture pour se
déplacer et ça c'est un impôt direct qui
est finalement très inégalitaire dont à
mon sens merci beaucoup rester avec nous
on continue ce débat sur le pouvoir
d'achat at il baissé ou diminuer en
fonction des ddd différentes
statistiques
ces méthodes de calcul sont elles en
phase avec la réalité on en débat dans
quelques instants
là tout de suite
[Musique]
est ce pas me parler de fracture entre
le nord de l'europe et le sud
on sait qu'il ya une fracture on sait
qu'il ya des pays qui ont été mal géré
vous avez deux pays de la zone euro et
donc les pays du sud qui n'ont pas
encore retrouvé leur niveau de richesse
d'avant la crise vous avez la grèce et
aussi lit-on malgré tout les aides qu'on
a pu avoir au niveau de nouvelles de nos
ventes a pas réussi à sortir de la crise
c'est à dire qu'on parle de la baisse du
chômage au portugal ou en espagne
en fait c'est simplement que vous avez
une grosse partie de la population et
des jeunes sont partis le drame c'est
que tous ces pays die notamment chez
nous en france des publics a augmenté
mais n'a pas généré de croissance est
lente
je ne sais pas qui est la locomotive de
l'europe en tout cas ne croyez pas que
ce soit la france
[Musique]
à
mais
[Musique]
l'europe la france aujourd'hui on a du
mal à comprendre ce qui s'y passe les
chiffres sont bons personnes écoutant
c'est à dire que la désindustrialisation
de la france très très fort depuis 20
ans s'est traduite par des fermeture de
milliers d'usinés
peu de gens osent le dire mais je le dis
il ya un retour en allemagne depuis une
dizaine d'années d'un mépris pour la
france parce que les allemands n'ont pas
compris qu'un pays adultes se laissent
des industrialisés comme nous l'avons
fait et ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
depuis 50 ans on est en déficit que la
conjoncture soit bonne ou mauvaise
devant encore vous dire que vous vous
comparer à l'allemagne
je ne rentre pas dans cette approche des
gens qui sous-estiment l'allemagne et
l'allemagne est en fait tant son
insertion dans l'économie mondiale dans
la même position que le japon donc
l'allemagne n'est pas foutu est donc la
clé serbe pourrait être l'entente entre
la france et l'allemagne
la question reste sur la table dans la
mesure où ça fait dix ans que les
allemands bloque tout l'initiale
historique
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite avec benoît ourliac
statisticien économiste à aline ses fils
y perd un économiste et auteur de
pouvoir d'achat le grand mensonge aux
éditions eyrolles et nicolas vidal
directeur de publication de putsch
médias le 17 novembre 2018 des dizaines
de milliers de liégeois descendus dans
les rues de france pour réclamer plus de
pouvoir d'achat depuis des mesures
d'urgence et d'autres ont été prises par
le gouvernement
mais le sentiment de ne pas en avoir
pour son argent demeure à strasbourg
comme partout dans le pays près d'un
français sur deux ne voit pas
d'amélioration dans son quotidien
il ya forcément une hausse des dépenses
il ya un phénomène d'inflation qui est
caché à la population
1 parce que je pense que l'intégration à
la zone euro a été mal faite
voilà donc ça c'est une analyse un vous
allez nous là nous l'a décrite et
philippe herlin on nous cache
l'inflation l'inflation est clair on pas
l'impression est calculé est ce qu'elles
donnent une réelle indication sur leur
nom non comme jeudi le ta l'heure il ya
déjà le problème du logement qu'elle
sous-estimé
il ya un autre aussi ce subterfuge pour
moi c'est rien d'autre que l'effet
qualité c'est à dire s'ils parlent si
vous changez vos smartphones vous
acheter de nouveaux qui vient de sortir
il est plus cher que l'ancien bon pour
vous basse et une perte de pouvoir
d'achat c'est concret mais lindsay veut
dire non dans changés non plus être
obligé d'écouter quelques années vu
l'évolution bon voilà donc pour vous
c'est une perte de pouvoir d'achat mais
l'insee vallières non en fait il est
plus performant il a plusieurs
fonctionnalités le possesseur forme plus
vite donc il ya donc il ya plus de
qualité donc vous avez plus pour votre
argent
donc dans sa base l'insee va mettre un
prix inférieur au prix étiquette
voilà et ça ça concerne ça concerne pas
que les produits technologiques ça
concerne aussi si vous vous juste prix
la préférée du matin ils sont prêts
augmente pas pour vous voilà ça coûte
plus cher mais mais s'il ya plus de
vitamines de l'insee va dire oui mais la
qualité augmente donc pour nous il n'y a
pas d'augmentation de prix voire et ça
concerne un quart des produits de l'
indice des prix donc ça fait beaucoup et
ça ça contribue à grignoter de quelques
dixièmes de pour cent tous les ans voilà
donc nos billets plus l'effet qualité ça
contribue à rogner un peu de l'inflation
réelle et hassan ou sortir un pouvoir
d'achat en progression ou même un
stagnation alors moi je dis qu'ils
baissent et ils baissent depuis
pas seulement depuis 2007 il pèse depuis
2000 ce que 2010 à la hausse de
l'immobilier comme j'ai dit à l'heure et
aussi la hausse des matières premières
qui commença que l'on voit partout et
qui est qui vient notamment parce que
les banques centrales notamment la
banque centrale américaine a commencé à
changer de politique après le krach du
nasdaq en demies depuis les attentats du
11 septembre 2001 il fallait absolument
éviter une crise donc on baisse les taux
d'intérêt ont fait un peu planche à
billets il ya plus de dollars en
circulation donc ceux qui détiennent des
actifs réels du pétrole dû faire du cuir
ils se disent il ya plus de dollars ça
va perdre de la valeur donc je
n'augmente mépris et envoie à partir de
2000 une augmentation de 2 lits matières
premières énergie et est aussi
alimentaire parce que et ça se traduit
dans les prix parce que s'ils prix du
blé sur l'essence voilà si le prix du
blé augmente va au bout d'un moment vous
payez vos clubs plus cher si le prix du
pétrole augmente les sens c'est plus
cher et si avec ça c'est des dépenses
contraintes on peut pas les éviter alors
il ya des baisses de prix sur les télés
couleurs les ça c'est clair que les
prêts ont baissé mais on n'en changent
pas régulièrement
par contre les dépenses alimentaires
l'énergie et l'habitation s'est
déchaussé des dépenses qu'on peut pas
reporter sont vitales et quand elles
augmentent bas on est coincé voilà c'est
ce qui s'est passé et je veux dire les
gilet jaune ne sont pas imaginable si le
pouvoir d'achat avait progressé depuis
2000 parce que ce sont des gens qui
n'avaient jamais manifesté à l'assaut et
puis sont pas les gens qui sont qui sont
en dehors du circuit au compteur ils ont
un travail et même un peu en général un
peu au dessus du smic ils ont fait un
projet de vie habitants campagne sur
place
ils ont une voiture ou deux ils ont ils
ont acheté un à un une maison ils ont
exemple en général ils travaillent tous
les deux ils ont des enfants bon ils ont
conçu leur budget pour que ça fonctionne
et ça a fonctionné au début et et si le
pouvoir d'achat côté d'augmenter ces
gens là n'auraient jamais manifestés
donc le fait qu'ils manifestent qui ce
qu'ils soient coincés suite à
l'augmentation de l'essence qui était un
peu la goutte d'eau mais pour les biens
qui a compensé les 17 milliards c'est
trop c'est trop ponctuelle c'est trop
petit trop ponctuelles pourront bel
janvier la zone sur la prime d'activités
aussi les choses vont baisser cette
année
nicolas vidal on a entendu cet habitant
de strasbourg dire aussi on a mal on
s'est même intégré dans l'europe
j'imagine que c'est l'euro parce que
beaucoup de français disent aussi
l'hommage a fait perdre du pouvoir
d'achat c'est difficilement quantifiable
est-ce que c'est réel ah ben il y avait
une étude parue par le centre politique
européen qu'il peut
l'officine bolchévique qui a noté entre
99 et 2017 de shead les chiffres que
j'ai lu que les français avaient perdu
56 mille euros depuis l'entrée l'euro
donc on peut le contester ou pas mais je
pense que plus largement la corrélation
avec le roma strich aussi à mon sens à
paupériser une partie de la population
et à saintes d une population en eux une
population ce que j'appelle la classe
aisée voire enid mondialisé qui habitent
dans les grandes villes
et puis une france périphérique qui
s'est retrouvé complètement qui a
peut-être moment donné dans les années
2000 ça c'est une impression que j'ai il
ya peut-être essayé de suivre ça en
achetant de tous les téléphones
portables va essayer d'avoir une fille
way of life africaine way of life et
qu'ils se sont rendu compte rapidement
que finalement déjà il n'avait pas la
main on parlerait traité lisbonne en
2005 où on va là où ils n'ont pas eu la
main démocratique da cieux ça a été un
viol démocratique mais aussi de façon
plus plus clair et plus efficiente
ils se sont rendu compte qu'ils
pouvaient pas suivre cette
mondialisation ce n'est pas les moyens
financiers de le faire parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas de capital il n'avait pas
de choses de côté ils étaient ils des
bouleaux et boulot on a dit tout à
l'heure
la dizaine d'utilisation a fait mal
aussi parce que ces gens se sont
retrouvés à un moment donné privés
d'emploi privé de qualifications dans un
monde qui a changé qui a été globalisé
qui a été mondialisé où ça a été d une
concurrence intra-européenne entre les
pays on l'a dit tout à l'heure
donc je crois qu'effectivement way 70
ans parce que je pense que les petits
mais une corrélation entre l'union
européenne et l'euro le passage à l'euro
benoît l'union européenne aussi je crois
benoît or les accès des secours
qu'est-ce que lindsay a tenté de
quantifier justement ce passage à l'euro
du franc à l'euro ou pas du tout il ya
eu des études de fait il ya des études
qui ont été faites au moment du passage
à l'euro fiduciaire notamment pour voir
comment avez évolué les prix du fait du
changement de monnaie ce qu'on a ce
qu'on avait observé à l'époque c'est
qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
d'inflation particulières liées à ce
changement de
à ce changement de
deux monnaies en fait après y avait
évidemment quand on a changé de monnaie
il a fallu faire des arrondis donc
notamment sur les petits les biens les
petits achats les arrondis ont plutôt
été voilà les arrondis ont plutôt été à
la faveur des commerçants
c'est ce qu'on observait pour les petits
produits pour les grands produits de
grande consommation qui coûte cher ça a
été plutôt l inverse est globalement
l'un dans l'autre ça ce qu'on pensait et
donc on n'a pas observé vraiment de
valse des étiquettes au moment du
passage du moment du passage à l'euro
alors je réponds que je vous en prie
vous lire agit en fait moi je mets pas
ça sort de l'euro je trouve que l'euro
sert de bouc émissaire pour
l'augmentation des prix même si on était
resté au franc on aurait subi la même
paire de pouvoir d'achat les américains
subissent ou si même genre de problèmes
bon c'est des phénomènes exogènes le
fait que l'euro soit une monnaie forte
c'est nous mêmes un peu protégés de
l'augmentation des matières premières
maintenant ce qui a joué en défaveur
c'est que la division par 6,5
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on fait de
tête donc on a perdu des références de
prix voilà là il exerça c'est ce que
leur fait dire avons payé en euros notre
baguette de pain aujourd'hui ont à peine
ouvert franc pardon aujourd'hui c'est un
euro donc là pour le coup c'est c'est
pas une grosse et ça c'est pas aussi
simple que ça mais c'est vrai que vous
vous payez la baguette de pain je pense
que c'était à bongo de naissance au
passage un message à l'euro à non non
non non c'est ce que vous savez combien
coûtait un rite de passage voilà ce sera
intéressant
du coup on a pas on va vérifier 60 à 60
centimes d'euro
d'accord donc ce qui est plus ce qui est
beaucoup plus qu'un franc e
on a alors 32 me dit on aurait
effectivement donc elles étaient elles
étaient plus chers deux tiers de moins
que 1 euro
on va dire on continue évidemment sur ce
pouvoir d'achat avec notamment une
mesure qui a plombé aussi le pouvoir
d'achat c'est la loi et galim qui a
voulu favoriser les agriculteurs et qui
finalement les qui au bout
ne leur ont pas bénéficié ce sont les
consommateurs qui payent écoutez depuis
le 1er février dernier
les prix des produits alimentaires en
surface sont augmentés augmenté du fait
de la loi alimentation qui a changé les
règles concernant la revente à perte est
en réalité c'était le prix en dessous
duquel il n'est pas possible de vendre
un produit
et cette mesure était présentée comme
une mesure bonne pour l'heure les
revenus des agriculteurs mais en réalité
cette inflation supplémentaire pour les
consommateurs c'est près d'un milliard
d'euros par an elle va être captée par
la grande distribution d'une part et par
l'industrie agroalimentaire d'autres pas
et donc les consommateurs vont payer
plus cher et les corps et les
agriculteurs en bout de chaîne ne
verront pas cet argent supplémentaire en
termes de revenus c'est donc une mesure
une sorte de jeu de dupes où les
consommateurs payent pour ne pas
rémunérer les agriculteurs et pour
rémunérer les grandes surfaces et les
grands industriels l'humour dont la
suppression de cette mesure alors là
aussi la loi et galina effet effet
ricochet ce sont les consommateurs
finalement qui paye au bout de la chaîne
philippe herlin il faut la supprimer
comme le réclame elle va y gagner
c'est l'exemple ce qu'il faut pas faire
parce que on c'est l'état qui dit quelle
marge sur quels produits vont devoir
faire les on revient au contrôle des
prix face à une conception soviétique de
l'économie alors qu'on sait alors porter
il faudra libéralisé il faut favoriser
la concurrence au contraire pour faire
baisser les prix
donc c'est vraiment une catastrophe et
là encore on peut je crois on peut
mettre un peu en cause une c est parce
que quand on regarde l'augmentation des
prix alimentaires sur février
l'année dernière l insee c'est plusieurs
2 je regardais alors c'est zéro
globalement sur le mois
plusieurs d'eux sur l'alimentaire mais
quand on regarde sur l'institut nielsen
qui a suivi une certaine de produits
alimentaires c'est +4 2% et là on voit
que lindsay a peut-être du mal à avoir
le mot tassement des prix
sur des effets rapides et sage de
l'explication après le lancement livia
une personne quand je présente élite qui
m'a expliqué qu'elle était qu'à relever
les prix pour insee et disaient c'était
tellement mal payés qu'en fait signe à
ben oui son job de relever les prix dans
les magasins c'était tellement mal payés
que en fait qu'ils remplissaient les
prix en partie des prix chez eux dans
leur salon quoi et quand on fait ça on a
tendance à projeter des moyennes passé
pour voir les prix futurs donc ça nous
rend aveugle par rapport à une
augmentation rapide des prix ce qui
s'est passé à kaluga nîmes et si
explique cette différence entre l'insee
plus ce genre de et l'institut nielsen
plus 4,2 de prix voilà benoît auriac
alors je vais répondre là dessus sur
plusieurs points dont j'ai alors laissé
un peu la parole
premièrement sur le loyer galim alors
plusieurs choses effectivement le d'un
reportage qui a été question d'un
milliard d'euros je sais pas du tout
comment a été fait cette estimation
c'est bien quand même de ramener
ce chiffre à la population française
parce que un milliard d'euros ça fait
grosso modo 15 euros par personne et par
an voilà c'est quand même pas non plus
énorme
ensuite quand on dit qu'on ne l'a pas vu
dans nos chiffres je suis pas du tout
d'accord
effectivement on ne l'a pas vu dans les
produits alimentaires parce qu'il ya eu
des boys baisse des hausses par contre
c'est quelque chose que l'on a vu sur
notre indice de prix des boissons
c'est sur les boissons et notamment les
boissons de marque que c'est portela ses
portes et la hausse des prix et ça
correspond bien est ce que l'on a mesuré
on en a parlé dans notre de conjoncture
de juin 2019
ça correspond bien à la hausse 2 à une
hausse de 0,1 point qui est qui
correspond à ce milliard d'euros aux
moines et cohérent pour comprendre
pourquoi la hausse des boissons alors
que là on parle des aides aux
agriculteurs parce que c'était dans
l'est alors je suis pas un spécialiste
de la loi s'est passé à l'hôtel qui est
qui et taxer davantage
non c'est pas ça c'est pas du tout en
lien avec la taxe soda
mais c'est lié au fait que
les grandes surfaces ont été contraintes
par la loi et galim à limiter les
remises qu'elle pouvait faire sur trois
surfaces alors qu'ils servaient de
produit d'appel et je suis pas sûr que
soit le choix des grandes surfaces
c'était quand même imposé par par la loi
d'accord on parle toujours de alors je
voudrais bien camion avant des points
parce qu'on a parlé d'une enquêtrice
d'une enquêtrice de l'insee qui étaient
mal payés qui était qu'ils étaient mal
payés alors
et qui disait mal faire son travail je
peux vous assurer que nos enquêteurs et
nos enquêteurs qui relève les prix font
vraiment leur travail de façon
extrêmement professionnelle avec l'une
éthiques
irréprochable d'autant que nous et nous
faisons aussi des contrôles des prix qui
sont relevés c'est à dire que de la
façon aléatoire
nous repassons derrière nos enquêteurs
de prix pour bien vérifier que leur
travail a été bien fait donc là dessus
évidemment on peut pas et on est
et comme toute organisation humaine on
n'est pas à l'abri de comportement
de compris en dédiant individuelle mais
on applique quand même des méthodes
rigoureuses contrôlé sur le plan de la
qualité pour s'assurer justement que les
relevés de prix sont bien faits donc
vraiment moi je veux pas qu'on mette en
cause le travail que font nos enquêteurs
qui est vraiment irréprochable et qui en
plus est bien contrôlée sur le plan de
la qualité
et qu'est ce qui rentre en compte dans
ce calcul notamment sur les produits de
consommation dans les supermarchés et
autres c'est un panel de produits qu'ils
aient décidé comment alors là justement
c'est une bonne question parce que c'est
juste ça vient tout juste de changer la
méthode
la méthode traditionnelle ctc on
sélectionne un panel de
un panel de produits consommation de
produits de consommation représentatifs
de la consommation de l'ensemble des
ménages français ont fait cette
sélection n'a juste ce panier tous les
ans on choisit un produit dans un
magasin données et tous les mois de
l'année
nos enquêteurs vont retourner dans ce
magasin pour voir comment a évolué le
prix de ce produit
donc ça c'est vraiment ce que l'on fait
pour l'ensemble des l'ensemble des biens
des biens et des services
ce qui se traduit par environ 200 mille
reflets de prix tous les mois
deux cent mille relevés de prix tous les
mois auquel s'ajoutent ensuite 500000
prix qui eux sont relevés sur internet
essentiellement avec des robots on a
développé ses techniques notamment pour
mieux prendre en compte les techniques
de yield management des entreprises
comme les billets de trains de la sncf
et la grande nouveauté qu'on a mis en
production cette année à compter du mois
de janvier c'est que on récupère
maintenant l'ensemble des données de
caisse des enseignes de la grande
distribution c'est à dire que ils nous
transmettent tous les mois l'ensemble
des informations des tickets de caisse
des clients qui passent dans leur
supermarché
donc là maintenant dans les grandes
surfaces dans les supermarchés liste
blanche et on est plus sur un
échantillon on est sur yon mesures
exhaustives de tout ce qui est vendu en
termes de produits alimentaires et
produits d'entretien alors on parle de
produits de consommation courante les ya
également la hausse du prix du tabac
nicolas vidal ça c'est une décision du
gouvernement d'augmenter les taxes et on
sait que évidemment ces impacts les plus
précaires ça ça pèse lourd ce budget
pourquoi est ce que le gouvernement
décide d'augmenter des taxes alors que
justement de pouvoir d'achat il sous
pression d'être trop penser à benjamin
griveaux qui lisait pas pour la faire
des questions mais plus est la france
périphérique finalement c'est le beauf
de camus c'est ce qui roule en diesel et
qui fument des clopes
oui mais on est toujours pareil on est
toujours sur une ponction et garonnais
d'impôts directs qui sont qui sauvent
supporter effectivement par une classe
de population et une nouvelle fois je
crois que c'est cette phrase de benjamin
griveaux il ya quand même quelque chose
car il a dit soyons clairs il ya une
forme de mépris de classe
on n'a pas encore parlé il ya un forme
de mépris de classe et je crois que
l'annexion de la réalité une telle
injection magali oui mais aussi ce
profond mépris c'est pareil ça je
voulais avoir mon regard d'alice
politique mais sur la perception si le
pouvoir d'achat quand je lis certains
partis à certaines déclarations
là je mets pas en cause 10 et je
corresponds sa politique christine
lagarde
il ya une forme de mépris ou s'ils ont
entendu les gens se rendent pas compte
plus factuellement c'est pas vrai où je
crois que c'est pas le renault
responsable politique ege amont à mon
sens il ya dans cette idée quand même
des choses comme ça et sur le tabac pour
en revenir à votre question oui on
essaie d'aller ponctionnés sur sur sur
les jeux sur le tabac et sur les choses
les choses
et pourtant selon le fce effectivement
il ya un réel décalage en tout cas pour
les pour les plus précaires qui sont
réellement impactée et qui ne
bénéficient pas des mesures
gouvernementales et qui sont impactées
par la hausse des taxes philippe herlin
ces inégalités en politiquement
quel choix devrait être opéré pour
davantage de justice en tout cas assez
souvent à l'achat le tabac il est pas
mal hein dis ça je crois que c'est
calculé sans tabac que que l'état prend
quand ça l'arrangé journal de pipe
il peut augmenter le prix du tabac sans
que ça est trop d'influencé pourtant
c'est plus cher mais c'est une dépense
en plus à favoriser le travail au noir
parce que les les
des tabacs proches des frontières de
vendre plus de tabac maintenant un temps
que voilà ou à paris un centre gaïa tout
un marché de l'or qu'ils développent
donc en plus sa déprime l'activité
économique quoi donc
bon voilà maintenant s'il ya aussi des
raisons de santé publique
il faut lutter contre la cigarette ça
chez moi je suis d'accord voilà mes mais
il faut peut-être le faire plus
intelligemment et pas en déprimant
activité économiquement
alors pour répondre aux questions sur
les que oui l'inflation et pouvoir
d'achat ce sont des moyennes bon on sait
bien qu'en économie les moyennes cesser
ces personnes est dans la moyenne
personne n'y est donc c'est donc
évidemment pour certains ménages qui
vont qui bénéficient pas des aides du
plan gilet jaune on va dire cela ils
peuvent ils peuvent plus souffrir quoi
c'est vrai bon et il faut aussi tenir
compte de ces solutions c'est pour ça
que moi je dis que à long terme ce qui
permet d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
s'est amélioré la productivité de
l'économie rien les cerises et la france
et puis de libéraliser de logements
c'est ça qui permet sur plusieurs années
d'avoir une espérance de gain de pouvoir
d'achat pour tous les français voilà
alors que caen faire de mesures
ponctuelles comme ça de distribuer de
l'argent en plus on n'a pas encore
financé par la dette
ça ça ça peut pas être satisfaisant ça
procure un peu de satisfaction pour
cette catégorie de personnes mais mais
c'est pas ça qui à long terme peut
redonner espoir aux gens et de se
projeter dans une progression de leur
pouvoir d'achat dans l'avenir on va
écouter
emmanuel macron c'était il y a quelques
jours à saint gervais justement il est
revenu sur le taux de chômage en france
tous ces emplois qui ont été sacrifiés
pendant la crise de 2008 écouter on
était les seuls
mais tel un de ceux qui avaient qui
avions détruit le plus d'emplois pendant
la crise est un des seuls à ne pas avoir
réussi à conjurer le chômage de masse
après crise on est en train de corriger
cela se rattraper mais il faut viser
beaucoup plus voilà le chômage de masse
qui a frappé la france comme d'autres
pays d'ailleurs mais on est là le seul
pays finalement qui n'arrive pas à
redresser la barre il s'était félicité
ce jour là des
des chiffres du chômage qui avait baissé
nicolas vidal
on est le seul pays qui n'a pas réussi à
redresser la barre c'est aussi ça elle a
la solution elle est là créer davantage
d'emplois et essayer de donner plus de
pouvoir d'achat il ya bien sûr mais je
vais revenir à l'union européenne à une
dépolitisation absolument pour moi de
l'économie nationale par rapport à ce
qu'on aille les gays à l'union
européenne en termes je parle des go pay
souvent les grands ont réussi votre
orientation pression de politique
économique là dessus on n'a pas la main
la réforme des retraites par exemple
c'est une chose mais la réforme des
retraites c'est aussi avec soin voilà
et il a dû à partie moment c'est
toujours côté de la souveraineté ou pas
est-ce qu'on reprend sa souveraineté ou
pas est-ce qu'on accepte la concurrence
libre et non faussée
est-ce qu'on veut se mettre en
concurrence avec tous les autres pays de
la zone euro c'est compliqué quand nous
allons pologne vous voyez que entre
l'aéroport de cracovie de l'outil
raconter la vie d'aujourd'hui vous avez
une conurbation de sièges sociaux
d'entreprises d'europe de chez nous donc
il ya finalement des gens qui ont
bénéficié de rue qui ont bénéficié et
finalement ça en partie cassé l'emploi
on va dire non qualifiés en france dont
le chômage de masse moi je veux bien
mais à un moment donné va falloir se
poser la question concrètement c'est
l'union européenne et de son impact sur
nos politiques
on a plus aujourd'hui pour moi ça c'est
un avis personnel on n'a plus la main ce
levier 20 politiques cherchent des
façons
l'union européenne interdit l'inflation
d'ailleurs c'est maintenant donc tout ça
à mon avis c'est lié c'est une
corrélation voilà il entend discuter et
on est la france qui défend néanmoins
son modèle social qui n'est pas le même
qu'en allemagne ou ailleurs la france
est le pays le plus redistributif aussi
en matière dette sociale
benoît benoît houria qu'est ce que çà çà
çà comme d'ailleurs ces inégalités est
ce que la la et les redistributions vous
avez travaillé sur cette question là
également est-ce qu'elle compense
réellement les inégalités la
redistribution réduit les inégalités ça
c'est sûr j'ai pas allégé pas les
chiffres en tête je suis désolé j'étais
pas venu avec mais ce sont des choses
sont déjà sont des choses que l'on
mesure que vous pouvez retrouver dans
nos publications que l'on fait tous les
ans ou en calcul quelles sont les clés
la distribution des niveaux de vie
quelles sont les inégalités avant et
après redistribution
donc on peut bien mesurer l'impact des
redistributions est ce que l'on à ce que
l'on monte c'est qu'effectivement on a
plutôt des inégalités qui serait dans la
moyenne d
européen avant redistribution mais après
redistribution on se re on est plutôt
dans le camp des pays les moins
inégalitaires
dans l'union européenne donc donc ça
joue
philippe herlin on est dans un pays avec
un système social qui est assez
protecteur finalement néanmoins de plus
en plus de français ne vont plus se
soigner toujours pour cette même raison
de pouvoir d'achat
ça c'est un vrai problème alors que les
soins a priori ne coûte rien et je pense
qu'on parle trop de redistribution et
pas assez de croissance
c'est ça aussi le problème de la france
c'est ça aussi la faille du modèle
social français qui coûtent trop cher
qui fait que les entreprises support
trop d'impôts et qui ne sont pas assez
combatif moi je mets pas en cause
l'europe
alors on peut mettre en cause la chine
ne verra peut-être pas dû rentrer dans
le réel c'est le testing chinois a causé
d'énormes dégâts dans tes skis français
je suis d'accord pour sa limite je veux
bien discuter mais pour la concurrence à
l'intérieur d'une europe aid pour moi la
france a toutes les chances de réussir
si on permettait aux entreprises d'être
plus agile d'avoir moins d'impôts
d'avoir une bourre à six mois moins
écrasante
on pourrait réussir chômage de masse
aussi alors on pourrait avoir un chômage
inférieur à 5 % comme l'autre tous les
pays européens qui fonctionne bien
bonds est l'objectif de cette personne
gouvernement c'est une façon de
reconnaître qu'on ne pourra pas y
arriver et ce qui est un peu dommage
qu'on pourrait être en dessous de 5%
il ya aucun problème pour ça maintenant
il faut il faut faire des réformes qui
passe à mon équipe comme puis passe à
mon avis par une diminution de dépenses
publiques pour pouvoir baisser les
impôts et là on va pouvoir relancer la
machine et l on sait que les gens
réclament les services publics il ya
aussi cette contradiction est dans le
ressenti on veut plus ou moins d'un les
gens ils veulent un travail bien payé et
services publics
ça vient après il voulait d'abord un
travail un travail bien payé et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut offrir aux
français si on décide de faire des
réformes plus importantes que ce que
fait le gouvernement aujourd'hui qui est
trop limité dans ses ambitions
allez on va passer aux questions
réponses et surtout le résultat de notre
sondage en ligne
[Musique]
la question ce soir sur nos réseaux
sociaux c'était l'action d'eads et gilet
jaune at elle fait augmenter votre
pouvoir d'achat et vous le voyez à
l'écran la réponse est non qu'à 87 1,1
pour cent 12,9 pour cent dix disent oui
l'action des gilets jaunes donc il
continue nicolas vidal dans la rue on le
voit tous les samedis maintenant avec
moins de personnes mais néanmoins
toujours les mêmes revendications et le
gouvernement lui qui ne répond pas donc
ce n'est pas suffisant encore notre
sondage qui reste un sondage arte france
bien sûr
oui a rien d'étonnant effectivement vous
l'avez dit dg des jeunes dans le
mouvement commence à mais il a été
remplacé maintenant par les opposants à
la réforme des retraites pour moi c'est
le franc my kiss ldj des jeunes la
réforme des retraites on aille à des
plus de gens qui ont peut-être pris
conscience cette idée là avec cette
réforme des retraites qui aujourd'hui
peut être aussi que oui après tout la
série de réformes voulues par emmanuel
macron mais on a une vraie crise de la
france périphérique aujourd'hui une
vraie crise de la souveraineté une vraie
crise de la consolante et monétaires
également donc je crois que cette crise
continuera à perdurer et être père les
dans le temps à mon sens c'est aussi
votre sentiment également philippe
herlin c'est une chose la llose de part
en part la réforme des retraites on
devrait développer au moins de façon
optionnelle la capitalisation les
capitalisations ça ferait plus d'argent
qui pourra s'investir dans l'économie
française bombe et ça c'est un tabou
aucun responsable politique à droite
comme à gauche ne veut parler de
capitalisation parce que c'est la
finance dérégulée m mais non c'est faux
ça permettrait de financer l'économie
voilà et ça fait des meilleures
retraites voilà habitat on veut pas en
parler ça remet en cause tous nos maux
sociaux les moyens d'encadrement tonale
par tous les moyens pour tout le monde
une réalisation d
orolia clos si vous voulez le mot de la
fin donc lindsay dont les enquêtes ont
souvent été remises en cause sur ce
pouvoir d'achat vous maintenez le
pouvoir d'achat a bien augmenté
je maintiens pouvoir d'achat augmenter
puisque vous venez au mot de la fin
vraiment j'invite
les personnes qui nous regardent à aller
sur notre site internet
tout ce que l'on fait est en accès libre
très bien documenté à regarder ce qu'il
y ait des choses très intéressantes sur
le pouvoir d'achat mais pas que ça sur
le taux d'effort en logements sur les
conditions de vie des ménages est
vraiment invisible parce qu'il ya de
quoi alimenter le débat public et le
diagnostic sur notre pays et c'est ce
qu'on a fait ce soir merci beaucoup en
tout cas à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat c'est la fin de deux pôles it mag
restez avec nous
[Musique]
le zéro derma pigmentosum c'est une
hypersensibilité aux rayons ultraviolets
en fait c'est une maladie génétique qui
est transmise par les deux parents dont
les deux parents sont porteurs